[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und
Herren ich war am vergangenen Dienstag
oder besser gesagt von Montag bis
Mittwoch in der Ukraine ein weiteres Mal
das zweite Mal in meiner Amtszeit und
habe am frühen Morgen den Maidan besucht
jenen euromidan wo vor 10 Jahren viele
Ukrainer und Ukrainer auf die Straße
gegangen sind um zu demonstrieren für
die europäische Ausrichtung Ihres Landes
für Freiheit und Souveränität 100
Menschen haben an diesem Tag ihr Leben
gelassen für diesen Kampf für Freiheit
und Unabhängigkeit und dieser Tag
erinnert uns
daran wie hoch der Preis sein kann für
die Werte für die wir stehen für das
Leben dass wir in Freiheit leben wollen
und leben und heute 10 Jahre später seit
fast zwei Jahren jetzt kämpfen die
ukrainerinen und Ukrainer wieder für
ihre Freiheit gegen einen Aggressor von
außen der sich das Recht nimmt mit
Gewalt Grenzen zu verschieben und die
Zivilbevölkerung mit kriegerischem
Terror zu
überziehen und sie kämpfen gegen einen
russischen Aggressor der ihnen wieder
die Freiheit und die Souveränität nehmen
will und in allen Gesprächen die ich
führen konnte unter anderem in einem in
einer Ausbildungseinheit eine Stunde
außerhalb von Kiev und auf einer Patriot
Stellung konnte ich mich war ich wieder
einmal mehr sehr beeindruckt von dem Mut
und der Entschlossenheit der
ukrainischen Soldatinnen und Soldaten
diesen Kampf weiterzuführen und es ist
ein schwerer es ist ein anstrengender
ein fordernder Kampf und ich habe bei
der Gelegenheit deutlich gemacht dass
unsere Unterstützung nicht nachlassen
wird und ich weiß und darüber bin ich
froh und dankbar dass ich mit dieser
Aussage die Breite die Überbreite
Mehrheit dieses Hauses hinter mir
weiß und unsere Unterstützung darf nicht
nachlassen weil ein Sieg
katastrophale Folgen hätte für
Deutschland für Europa für die
internationale regelbasierte Ordnung
insgesamt und eine Folge dieses
Krieges ist die wir müssen wieder
wehrhafter werden die Erkenntnis ist wir
müssen wieder whrhafter werden wir
müssen gemeinsame Verantwortung und
Führung in der NATO übernehmen um unsere
Sicherheit und unsere Freiheit im Falle
eines Angriffs verteidigen zu können mit
den verteidigungspolitischen Richtlinien
auf der Grundlage der
Sicherheitsstrategie haben wir jetzt die
die wichtigsten Weichen gestellt es sie
sind die Richtschnur für die Ausrichtung
des Geschäftsbereich des BMVg auf die
Zeitenwende und das ganz klar mit dem
kernauftrag wieder mit dem kernauftrag
Landes und bündnisverteidigung und dazu
gehört auch die Brigade lown die wir auf
den Weg gebracht haben und für die die
Roadmap jetzt demnächst fertig werden
wird das ist Ausdruck von
Führungsverantwortung das ist Ausdruck
dessen dass wir zuverlässiger Bündnis
Partner innerhalb der NATO sind und sein
wollen und es geht darum Sicherheit und
Abschreckung wieder gewährleisten zu
können sie sind wieder
unverzichtbar so traurig diese Realität
auch ist und deswegen ist es notwendig
auch in den nächsten Jahren intensiv zu
investieren in die Bundeswehr in die
Truppe in die Ausstattung in die
Ausbildung damit wir diesem Auftrag
wieder gerecht werden können und ich bin
sehr froh dass es in dieser Frage auch
angesichts der aktuell sehr angespannten
Haushaltssituation einen breiten Konsens
in diesem Hause gibt und dafür danke ich
Ihnen von Herzen denn wir
alle denn wir alle haben gemeinsam eine
Verantwortung für die Bundeswehr damit
Sie uns und unsere Partner im Ernstfall
effektiv und wirkungsvoll verteidigen
kann vielen
Dank vielen Dank das Wort für den
zweiten einleitenden Bericht hat nun der
Bundesminister für Gesundheit dr Kar
Lauterbach fr Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren zunächst
einmal möchte ich dem
Bundesverteidigungsminister danken für
diese klaren Aussagen möchte darauf
hinweisen dass Deutschland auch die
Ukraine unterstützt bei der Versorgung
von Schwerstverletzten die innerhalb der
Ukraine nicht versorgt werden können
Deutschland nimmt mehr dieser
Schwerstverletzten auf wie jedes andere
europäische Land das ist nichts was wir
öffentlich groß kund tun das ist nichts
was wir medial verwerten sondern se eine
Pflicht die wir haben und wir Teil
verteilen diese Patienten auf
Krankenhäuser die hochspezialisiert sind
wir tragen diese Kosten und das ist eine
Leistung die wir der Ukraine Schulden
ich möchte hier klarstellen wir werden
das tun wir werden das Fortsetzen
solange wie es nötig ist wir werden die
diese Schwerstverletzten die auch unsere
Freiheit hier verteidigen nicht im Stich
lassen wir werden sie nehmen und
versorgen solange wie das notwendig
ist lassen Sie mich bei dieser
Gelegenheit auch darauf hinweisen dass
wir den Schwerstverletzten und dass wir
denjenigen die versorgt werden müssen in
Israel unsere Solidarität nicht nur
mitgeteilt haben sondern dass wir Israel
unterstützen unterstützt haben auch mit
ger
mit Produkten mit
Medizinprodukten wenn man diese Produkte
beschafft und wenn man versucht diese
Produkte dann zur Verfügung zu stellen
dann kann man sich als Arzt ein Bild
davon machen wie schwer der Terror
dieses Land betroffen hat kann man sich
ein Bild davon machen wie schlimm es
diesen Menschen ergangen ist lassen Sie
mich daher an dieser Stelle sagen wir
stehen fest an der Seite Israels im
Kampf gegen den Terror wir stehen fest
an der Seite Israels im Kampf gegen die
Hamas
die Situation in Deutschland was unser
Gesundheitssystem angeht wir sind jetzt
in der Mitte der
Legislaturperiode ist geprägt durch
wichtige Reformen die ich gleich auch
Gelegenheit habe vorzustellen zu dürfen
möchte aber den Hintergrund jetzt mal
beschreiben das ist ein Hintergrund der
nicht vielen bekannt ist der aber in der
Klarheit ausgedrückt werden muss sonst
versteht man die Größe der
Reformvorhaben nicht der Hintergrund ist
der der wird ja jetzt zunächst einmal
denken Deutschland ein reiches Land kein
Land gibt mehr für Gesundheitsversorgung
aus pro Kopf in Europa als Deutschland
das macht man wird vermuten wir hätten
die beste Lebenserwartung wir hätten die
beste Gesundheitsversorgung die beste
Lebenserwartung Wahrheit ist aber wenn
man die 16
westeuropäischen Länder in Europa
vergleicht dann liegen wir an letzter
und an vorletzter Stelle für Männer und
für Frauen wir sind abgeschlagen die
Lebenserwartung entwickelt sich nicht
günstig die
lebenserwartungsunterschiede im
Vergleich zu Ländern die sich besser
entwickeln wachsen wir haben ein Problem
wir geben viel aus unser System ist
ineffizient wir haben zu oft einen Weg
gewählt der nicht weiterträgt der Weg
ist der wir verändern nicht die
Strukturen aber wir geben mehr Geld in
die nicht funktionierenden Strukturen
diesen Weg dürfen diesen Weg können wir
nicht mehr miteinander
gehen
ich bin daher dankbar dass die Ampel
hier ehrgeizige Ziele verfolgt und ich
möchte nur auf drei große Bereiche
Hinweisen wir haben gleich bei ihren
fragenelegenheit zu vertiefen der erste
Bereich ist der die Art und Weise wie
wir unsere Krankenhäuser finanzieren ist
nicht richtig das
fahpauschalensystem belohnt
Minderqualität belohnt
Rosinenpickerei belohnt die Versorgung
von Patienten die auch ambulant versorgt
werden könnten wenn sie stationär
versorg gt werden können das macht
keinen Sinn müssen Umsteigen auf ein
System wo die Vorhaltung der Leistung
bezahlt wird vorhalte pauschalen wo
Qualität vergütet wird und wo der
ökonomische Druck aus dem System
herausgenommen wird das ganze System
kann nur funktionieren wenn die Leistung
auch transparent ist es kann nicht sein
dass der Patient in Deutschland nicht
die Möglichkeit hat im Falle einer
Krebserkrankung das wird im nächsten
Jahr 500.000 Menschen und mehr betreffen
sich zu informieren wo ist in der Region
für mich die beste Versorgung das kann
kein Geheimwissen sein das ist etwas was
die Bevölkerung benötigt eine
Transparenz die wir schaffen werden eine
Transparenz die nicht jeder möchte aber
es ist ein ethisches Gebot dass jeder
die für sich geeignete Versorgung finden
kann und für seine leebsten das ist ein
recht was wir auch für uns selbst in
Anspruch nehmen Herr Minister sie können
jetzt nicht weiter ausführen weil die
Zeit ist um für die einleit ich danke
Ihnen und das veranlasst mich direkt zu
dem Hinweis bevor wir jetzt in die Fr
Fragestunde einsteigen dass alle sich an
die vorgegebenen Zeiten und auch die
beiden Minister bitte an die
vorgegebenen Zeiten der Beantwortung
halten und wir beginnen jetzt mit den
Fragen zu den beiden Berichten und dem
Geschäftsbereich der anwesenden
Mitglieder der Bundesregierung und
zuerst hat das Wort zur ersten Frage der
Kollege aus der CDU CSU Fraktion Thomas
röwkamp sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrter Herr Minister
pestorius die Lage für die Ukraine im
Kampf gegen den russischen Angriffskrieg
ist nach verschiedenen Berichten aus den
letzten Tagen und Wochen schwierig und
ernst und der russische generalstatschef
salusni warnte kürzlich vor einem
Stellungskrieg wie im ersten
Weltkrieg wir sind uns auch nach ihren
einführenden Worten von eben einig dass
die Ukraine eben auch unseren Frieden
und unsere Freiheit verteidigt und sie
waren wie sie eingangs bemerkt haben
jüngst in Kiev meine Frage ist schätzen
auch sie die militäris Lage in der
Ukraine als so gefährlich ein und wäre
es jetzt nicht umso wichtiger dass der
Marschflugkörper Taurus um den die
Ukraine sie ja auch bei ihrem Besuch
persönlich gebeten hat jetzt zügig
geliefert
wird sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
Abgeordnete abgeordn rög zunächst mal
wer wäre ich die Einschätzung der des
führenden Generals der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte in Frage zu stellen in der
Tat erleben wir einen Krieg der viele
Merkmale eines abnutzungs und
Stellungskrieges hat der gleichzeitig
massiv Hybrid geführt wird auch auf
andere Art und Weise wie wir wissen und
ja die Prognose ist schwer wohin dieser
Krieg sich in den nächsten Monaten über
den Winter erst recht aber danach
entwickelt da da erlaube ich mir
Prognosen nicht abzugeben weil ich damit
ziemlich alleine wäre das zu tun was den
Taurus Marchl angeht habe ich in der
Vergangenheit mehrfach betont es gibt
dazu keinen neuen Sachstand und ich habe
auch heute keinen
neuen sie dürfen
stellen eine Nachfrage stellen Herr
Minister können Sie denn mir und dem
Plenum einen für sie
nachvollziehbaren Grund dafür liefern
dass Deutschland den
Marschflugkörper nicht liefert wo doch
unsere Partner Frankreich Großbritannien
und die USA mit vergleichbaren Waffen
beliefern deren Ziel ja ist zum einen
die russischen Versorgungslinien hinter
der Front anzugreifen aber zum anderen
auch die Stellungen zu zerstören von
denen aus die russische die ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung jeden Tag mit Raketen
und Drohnen angegriffen
wird sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Abgeordnete zunächst einmal die
Grundannahme trifft nicht zu es gibt
keine dem Taurus Marschflugkörper
ähnlichen Flug Marschflugkörper die von
anderen geliefert worden sind weder die
amerikanische C mit einer Reichweite
von5 km noch Storm Shadow noch das
französische Modell haben eine auch nur
annähernd vergleichbare Reichweite wie
die Taurus zum zweiten hat es mir
gegenüber in der Ukraine keine
offizielle Anfrage nach Taurus Lieferung
gegeben in dem Gespräch was ich geführt
habe weil die Kollegen auf der
ukrainischen Seite wissen dass die
Position der Ukraine der Position der
Bundesregierung nach wie vor die ist die
ich ihn geschildert habe es gibt keinen
neuen
Sachstand die nächste Frage stellt aus
der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen janor
Stamm sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ich
würde gerne den
Bundesgesundheitsminister fragen wollen
sehr geehrte Herr Minister die Länder
die Bundesländer haben mit mit Mehrheit
am vergangenen Freitag im Bundesrat
entschieden dass sie das
Transparenzgesetz an den
Vermittlungsausschuss überweisen wollen
das Gesetz enthält ja wichtige
Liquiditätshilfen für die Krankenhäuser
und soll für mehr Transparenz für die
Patientinnen Patienten sorgen
können Sie vielleicht einiges an
Argumenten sagen warum es falsch wäre
dieses Gesetz auf die lange Bank zu
schieben oder gar nicht zu verabschieden
was werden die Konsequenzen
davon
frau Präsidentin Herr Abgeordneter ich
darf mich für die Frage ganz herzlich
bedanken zunächst einmal in dem
Transparenzgesetz ist geregelt dass die
eben von mir beschriebene Transparenz
regional welche Klinik für welchen
Eingriff viel Erfahrung hat wie oft der
Eingriff gemacht wird mit welchen
Ergebnissen ob es HT zu Komplikationen
kommt ob man Fachärztinnen und fachärzt
oder nicht diese Transparenz wird im
Gesetz geregelt und ist dringend
notwendig damit wir im nächsten ja eine
bessere Versorgung bekommen werden
darüber hinaus ist es auch so dass in
diesem Gesetz mindererlöse in der Pflege
ausgeglichen werden sollen in der
Größenordnung von 6 Milliarden Euro Geld
was die Krankenhäuser im nächsten Jahr
an Liquidität unbedingt benötigen werden
wenn dieses Geld nicht fließen würde ist
ein ansonsten abwendbares flächendecken
des krankenhaussterben möglicherweise
nicht abwendbar und der dritte Punkt ist
also in diesem Transparenzgesetz werden
auch die Grundlagen dafür geschaffen
dass das eigentliche krankenhausgesetz
umgesetzt werden kann wir würden sonst
Zeit verlieren somit glaube ich dass wir
im Vermittlungsausschuss die Länder von
der unbedingten Notwendigkeit dieses
Gesetzes überzeugen können sie dürfen
eine Nachfrage
stellen vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich
würde den Minister gerne noch fragen
wollen die Bundesländer haben
vorgetragen öffentlich aber auch in der
entsprechenden Bundesratssitzung dass
sie unabhängig von den 80 Milliarden die
jährlich in Deutschland für die
Krankenhausversorgung zur Verfügung
stehen äh und den energiehilfen den
inflationshilfen den coronahilfen die
vom Bund geflossen sind nun weitere 5
Milliarden äh als Überbrückungshilfen
als Vorschaltgesetz haben wollen halten
Sie es für wahrscheinlich dass auch
angesichts des Urteils in Karlsruhe vor
einigen Wochen solche zusätzlichen
Gelder neben all den anderen Hilfen auch
fließen werden eine solche Forderung
hatte ich für unerfüllbar und auch für
unbegründet zunächst einmal im letzten
Jahr sind im ersten Halbjahr in diesem
Jahr sind im ersten Halbjahr die
krankenhausausgaben um 7 % gestiegen der
Bund hat 420 Millionen zusätzlich für
kinderhallkunde und Geburtshilfe zur
Verfügung gestellt 6 Milliarden
energiehilfen werden den Krankenhäusern
zugute kommen mehr als in jedem anderen
Wirtschaftsbereich somit ist der
Krankenhausbereich im aufwuchs und würde
jetzt noch einmal 6 Milliarden
Liquiditätshilfe bekommen der Bund hat
also dauerhaft stetig in großen Summen
gezahlt der weil die Länder im letzten
Jahr 3inh Milliarden Euro
Investitionskosten schuldig geblieben
sind es kann nicht sein dass der Bund
immer zahlt und die Länder ihren
Verpflichtungen nicht nachkommen daher
die Antwort ist nein eine solche
Forderung ist
unbegründet die nächste Frage stellt aus
der AFD Fraktion Rüdiger
[Applaus]
Lukassen
frau Präsidentin meine Frage richtig ich
an den Herren Bundesminister
Pistorius Herr Minister der
Verfassungsbruch den die Bundesregierung
mit der Aufstellung des Haushaltes
begangen hat war das bestimmende Thema
der letzten Woche das be
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ihrer
Regierung amtlich bescheinigt dass sie
keine Kontrolle über die Ausgaben haben
und dass sie diesen Kontrollverlust
verfassungswidrig wegtrixsen wollen in
der Folge werden nun alle Einzelpläne
auch der Einzelplan 14 Verteidigung auf
Einsparung untersucht werden müssen ihr
Finanzminister spricht von einem
erheblichen Konsolidierungsbedarf die
Frage Herr Minister an welcher Stelle
werden sie dem Finanzminister
Einsparungen im verteidigungset
[Applaus]
anbieten jetzt sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Abgeordneter
bislang kann ich nur so viel sagen es
gibt keinerlei Anforderung an meinen et
einspar oder konsolidierungsbeiträge zu
liefern sowohl das Sondervermögen als
auch der Einzelplan 14 scheinen
vorbehaltlich der parlamentarischen
Entscheidung unangetastet zu bleiben und
ich halte das auch für
richtig sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen Frau danke schön frau
Präsidentin Herr Minister können Sie
auch für die Zukunft ausschließen dass
wenn es doch zu von ihnen zu
identifizierenden Einsparpotenzial aus
Einzelplan 14 kommen soll und sie mit
der Mehrheit der Ampel das
sonderfinanzierungsgesetz dahingehend
ändern dass auch andere Vorhaben durch
das Sondervermögen bezahlt werden können
dass sie wegen dieses Druckes des
Finanzministers eine Umschichtung vom
Einzelplan 14 auf das Sondervermögen
machen
werden frau Präsidentin ordneter wie
könnte ich das ausschließen ich kann
nicht in die Zukunft gucken stand heute
ist dass es diesen diese Anforderung an
meinen Plan Einzelplan nicht geben wird
auch nicht in ein Sondervermögen und
damit plane ich bis auf
weiteres die nächste Frage stellt aus
der SPD Fraktion Johannes
alt ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Frage geht an den Bundesminister
der Verteidigung sehr geehr her Minister
sie haben sich in den letzten Monaten ja
offen in den Medien gezeigt für eine
Einführung eines Gedenktages für unsere
Veteraninnen und Veteranen und in ihrer
Rede bei der Eröffnungszeremonie zu den
invctus Games im September in Düsseldorf
haben sie diejenigen gewürdigt die Leib
und Leben für Freiheit Sicherheit und
für unser Land riskiert haben und oft
gerätt ja ein bisschen aus dem Fokus
dass wir 10 Millionen weteraninnen und
Veteranen in Deutschland haben von denen
auch über 500.000 in einem
Auslandseinsatz Dienst geleistet haben
und ähm genau für diesen Einsatz
gebietet Ihnen unser Respekt unsere
Wertschätzung es gibt entsprechende
Gedenktage ja bereits in den USA und in
den Niederlanden und meine konkrete
Frage wäre an sie auf welchem Wege ließe
sich ein solcher Veteranentag in
Deutschland realisieren und wie sollte
er auch ausgestaltet
seinte frau Präsidentin Herr
Abgeordneter ja ich habe in der Tat
mehrfach schon gesagt ich halte die
Einführung eines veteranentages
äh neben dem eines veteranenbüros das
wir jetzt schon in Berlin haben
ausdrücklich für richtig und auch
zeitgemäß wir brauchen eine Wert eine
Zeichen dieser ein dieses ein Zeichen
dieser Art von Wertschätzung für die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten unserer
Streitkräfte die für unser Land ihren
Dienst geleistet haben und nicht wenige
von ihnen im Ausland und nicht wenige
von diesen wiederum auch mit schweren
opfern für die eigene psychische oder
physische Gesundheit oder eben sogar mit
dem Leben bezahlt haben deswegen bin ich
sehr dafür dass wir unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten die soldatinen und Soldaten
einer Parlamentsarmee sind die also im
Auftrag des Parlaments ihre Einsätze
bestreiten dass diese Soldatinnen und
Soldaten mit einem Veteranentag geehrt
und gewertschätzt werden und ich bin für
jeden Vorschlag aus der Mitte des
Parlaments offen und werde ihn
konstruktiv
begleiten sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen vielen Dank Herr Minister
welchen Rahmen welcher Rahmen würde
ihrer Bewertung nach angemessen sein für
so einen Tag und welche
gesellschaftlichen Bedingungen können
für Veteran insgesamt noch verbessert
werden frau Präsidentin Entschuldigung
sehr geehrte Abgeordnete ich glaube wir
sind gut beraten das öffentliche
Bewusstsein für das was Soldatinnen und
Soldaten für uns leisten zu stärken und
dazu gehört ein Veteranentag dazu gehört
eine Überprüfung der Regelung die
Veteranen die bzw ehemalige Leist ja
ehemalige soldatinen Soldaten in den
Streitkräften zu Ehren eben auch zu
versorgen das ist glaube ich der
Zentrale Auftrag das muss ein
Gesamtpaket sein ein Veteran als solcher
ein alleine würde vermutlich nicht
reichen die nächste Frage stellt aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE Gesine
Lötsch frau Präsidentin meine Frage
richtet sich auch an den Bundesminister
Pistorius in unserem Grundgesetz steht
der Bund stellt Streitkräfte zur
Verteidigung auf nun sind sie mehrfach
von der Formulierung des Grundgesetzes
abgewichen und sprachen von
kriegstüchtig sie wissen dass ich das
sehr scharf kritisiere weil ich das für
eine gefährliche Formulierung halte ich
würde ihn gerne von Ihnen wissen ist
diese Veränderung und diese Abweichung
vom Grundgesetz durch einen Beschluss
des Kabinetts gedeckt oder ist das Ihre
persönliche
Meinung sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete
die Frage mutet befremdlich an denn im
Grundgesetz
stehtitkräfte zur aufzustellen ist
Aufgabe des Bundes genau das tun wir
seit mehreren Jahrzehnten was ist die
Aufgabe von Streitkräften die Aufgabe
von Streitkräften ist dann wenn wir
angegriffen werden einen Abwehr ein
Verteidigungskrieg zu führen um ein
Krieg führen zu können an diesen
abwehrkrieg führen zu können muss man
kriegstauglich muss man kriegstüchtig
sein man muss die Fähigkeiten besitzen
einen Krieg zu führen und genau darum
geht es und genau das habe ich gesagt
und gemeint und auch erklärt vielfach
von daher würde ich sagen ordne ich die
Frage unter die Rubrik ein sie wollen
eine Antwort haben die sie nicht
bekommen
können sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
ja vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich
bleibe dabei verteidigungsfähig ist das
Grundgesetz gedeckte Wort und ich finde
wir müssten friedenstüchtig werden und
nicht kriegstüchtig aber meine Nachfrage
sie haben sich ja mehrfach jetzt
geäußert auch auf Nachfrage zu der
Finanzierung und sie sagten sie gehen
davon aus dass der Einzelplan 14 so
stehen bleibt und auch das
Sondervermögen in den Beratungen die wir
in den kommenden Wochen haben werden nun
haben sich aber auch mehrfach geäußert
dass das eigentlich noch nicht ausreicht
wir haben nach natoriterien fast 85 über
85,5 Milliarden Euro im Einzelplan 14
zusätzlich das Sondervermögen wie viel
Geld brauchen sie ihrer Meinung nach bis
zu Jahr 27 also in der mittelfristigen
Finanzplanung zusätzlich um die
Bundeswehr ich wiederhole ihre Worte die
nicht meine sind kriegstüchtig zu machen
und an welchen Positionen würden sie im
Bundeshaushalt
kürzen frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Frau Abgeordnete zunächst mal begrüße
ich dass sie die Wort das Wort
kriegstüchtig in Vokabular aufnehmen
weil ich es nämlich für nötig halte die
zweite Antwort die zweite Antwort ist
wir gehen davon aus je nach Größe des
biip dann im Jahre 27 28 dass wir den et
im Einzelplan 14 zwischen 15 und
vielleicht 23 24 Milliarden Euro werden
aufstocken müssen das sind die Zahl über
die wir gerade reden und ja es sind 85
Milliarden dieses Jahr unter Einrechnung
des Sondervermögens und der
verteidigungsrelevanten Ausgaben anderer
Ressource um das aufwachsen zu lassen
ist dieser Betrag dann ab 28
erforderlich die nächste Frage stellt
aus der FDP Fraktion Marie Agnes
strackzimmermann vielen Dank frau
Präsidentin ich stelle die Frage an den
Bundesminister der Verteidigung Herr
Minister zuerst einmal vielen Dank dass
dass in die Ukraine gereist sind ein
wichtiges Zeichen gerade angesichts der
Tragödie in Israel hatte die Ukraine ja
Sorge dass wir sie nicht mehr im Fokus
haben wir hatten gestern gleichzeitig
mit einigen Abgeordneten trafen wir
ukrainische Soldaten die darüber
berichtet haben was sich für Grauen in
den besetzten in der besetzten
Ostukraine unter den Russen stattfindet
Mord Vergewaltigung Willkür
Beschlagnahmung keine Medizin Cholera
Ausbruch äh die Sprache darf nicht mehr
gesprochen werden die ukrainische
zeitgleich zu diesem Drama hat die
bildzeit 24 November ein Artikel
veröffentlicht mit der Überschrift neuer
Geheimplan Ukraine wo der
Bundesregierung und den Amerikanern
unterstellt wird nur so viel zu liefern
so wenig zu liefern um die Ukraine in
Verhandlungen zu drängen könnten Sie
freundlicherweise dazu etwas
sagen sehrrte frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Abgeordnete ich habe selten
einen abwegigeren Unsinn gelesen als
diesen
Zeitungsartikel ist
geradeade uns zu unterstellen wir würden
durch gelenkte durch reduzierte durch
was auch immer für Lieferungen die
Ukraine in eine Position bringen in die
sie nicht will das stimmt nicht das ist
nicht der Wahrheit mir ist nichts davon
bekannt im Gegenteil wir tun gerade
alles was möglich ist und beliefern die
Ukraine mit neuen Systemen sowohl zur
Luftverteidigung als auch gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge und Munition also wir haben
uns da gar nichts
vorzuwerfen sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen wir sind nicht nur an der Stelle
einer Meinung sondern mit Sicherheit
auch dass es wenn es um die Sicherheit
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland geht auch
darum geht das Bund Kommunen und das
Land dass wir alles dazu tun um dazu
beizutragen das große Problem Munition
ist bekannt das ist kein Geheimnis jetzt
erleben wir allerdings in der Stadt
trostdorf in Nordrhein-Westfalen dass
dort der CDU Bürgermeister seit Wochen
verhindert dass dort eine bestehende
Munitionsfabrik die auch die Erlaubnis
hat dieses herzustellen ihre Kapazität
erweitern würden um die Sicherheit der
Bundesrepublik K zu stellen und äh wenn
sie dazu mal ausführen könnten was da
passiert und ob wir nicht gesetzmäßig
auch dagegen vorgehen können dass wenn
es um die Sicherheit geht so etwas nicht
verhindert werden kann
komm frau Präsidentin Frau Abgeordnete
in der Tat von diesem Vorgang habe ich
gehört ich habe auch gestern mit dem
nordrin-westfähischen
Ministerpräsidenten dazu telefoniert von
gestern Abend habe ich dann erfahren
dass der Rat offenbar beschlossen hat
ich kenne den Beschluss nicht im
Wortlaut beschloss hat dass ein
Vorkaufsrecht seitens der Gemeinde für
dieses Areal um das es hier geht
ausgesprochen wird das heißt ein
Verfahren wird eingeleitet ein
Bieterverfahren es dauert alles
unglaublich lange Zeit dabei ist das
Interesse der Firma die dort bereits
einen Standort betreibt seit langem
bekannt und der Druck es dort zu
realisieren ist groß angesichts der
Situation die wir alle kennen nämlich
das Munition und die Produktion von
Explosivstoffen in Deutschland genau wie
Europa ein echter Engpass ist ein echtes
lieferkettenproblem und deswegen habe
ich ein großes Interesse daran dass auch
Länder und Kommunen hier mit uns an
einem Strang ziehen und diese
Realisierung nicht nur nicht zu
behindern sondern zu beschleunigen
helfen vielen Dank wir kommen nun zu
fragen zu den vorangegangenen
Kabinettssitzung und weiteren
Geschäftsbereichen sowie zu
allgemeinenfagen und die erste Frage
stellt aus der CDU CSU Fraktion Tino
Sorge sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Herr Minister
Lauterbach der Präsident des
Bundesverbandes der Kinder und
jugendärzte ihr erzlicher Kollege Thomas
Fischbach rechnet damit dass durch die
legalisierungspläne der Ampel der
Cannabiskonsum bei Jugendlichen
erheblich steigen wird er nennt die
Legalisierung eine Kapitulation vor der
Illegalität der chronische Gebrauch von
Cannabis mache salop gesagt doof und
könne auch Psychosen verursachen daher
sprechen sich nahezu alle ärzeverwendee
gegen diese Legalisierung aus und
insofern würde mich uns interessieren
wie sie als Bundesgesundheitsminister
und Mediziner diese Freigabe
verantworten
können sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte abgeordnet vielen Dank für
diese Frage zunächst einmal ich achte
die Einschätzungen von Herrn fichbach
sehr sein erfahrener Kinderarzt ein sehr
guter Kliniker jemand also der uns oft
beraten hat und uns hilft aber hier geht
es ja um die Einschätzung wie Cannabis
sich also auswirken wird auf die äh
Frage haben wir mehr Konsum haben wir
gefährlicheren Konsum die jetzige
Drogenpolitik ist gescheitert wir haben
stetig steigenden Konsum gerade bei
Kindern und bei Jugendlichen die jetzige
Politik kann nicht anders als geschatt
beschreben werden wir haben
Verunreinigungen wir haben Zunahme des
Konsums auch von anderen Drogen die
gefährlicher sind als Cannabis wir
überlassen diesen Markt diesen
Schwarzmarkt denjenigen die mit
krimineller Energie versuchen unser
Kinder und Jugendlichen in Abhängigkeit
zu bringen so kann es nicht weitergehen
daher verlassen wir uns auf die
wissenschaftliche Evidenz den Weg zu
gehen den Schwarzmarkt zu bekämpfen die
Verunreinigung zu bekämpfen und mit
einem ausgedehnten Kinder und
Jugendschutz die Abhängigkeit von
Kindern Verkauf an Kindern der ja
illegal bleibt zu
vermeiden sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen ja vielen Dank auch Herr
Minister dass sie das Thema Kinder und
Jugendschutz ansprechen deshalb ist es
ja umso befremdlicher dass sie im Rahmen
des Gesetzentwurfes jetzt auch im Rahmen
der Beratung innerhalb der Ampel wo das
Gesetz ja auch nicht ganz unumstritten
ist sich bei dem Thema Kinder und Jugend
Schutz durch verschiedene gesetzliche
Regelungen jetzt noch mal
verständigt haben nur eben nicht zu
Gunsten des Kinder- und Jugendschutzes
sondern sie haben beispielsweise sich
darauf verständigt dass schutzvorkehrung
also räumliche Abstände zu schulen zu
Kitas beispielsweise abgesenkt werden
also indem die Freigrenzen auch
heraufgesetzt werden bei der Frage wie
viel Cannabis man dann haben darf also
im Grunde ihr Schutzkonzept ist komplett
zerflettert word en und noch mal die
Frage wie können sie als
Bundesgesundheitsminister diesen
gefährlichen Weg
mitgehen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt steigt
der Konsum bei Kindern und bei
Jugendlichen wir haben mehr
Verunreinigungen wir haben einen
wachsenden Schwarzmarkt und so kann es
nicht weitergehen sie haben falsch
dargestellt dass wir den Kinder und
Jugendschutz verändert haben es bleibt
dabei Kinder und jugendschutz wird in
Aufklärungen betrieben und das der der
Verkauf an Kinder und Jugendliche bleibt
verboten der einzige also Veränderung
die wir in diesem Bereich vorgenommen
haben ist dass wir den also
bannenmäßigen Verkauf von über
21jährigen an Kinder und Jugendliche mit
einem höheren Strafmaß belegt haben von
mindestens 2 Jahren das ist die einzige
Veränderung die wir vorgenommen haben
diesen Bereich eine
Verschärfung ich habe zu diesem Thema
eine Nachfrage gesehen vom Abgeordneten
sich aus der AFD
Fraktion ja vielen Dank sie haben gerade
gesagt Sie wollen gegen Verunreinigungen
Vorgehen undun haben wir die
Verunreinigungen nicht nur bei Cannabis
wir haben die Verunreinigungen auch
jetzt bei den coronaimpfstoffen wo die
DNA Verunreinigungen festgestellt worden
sind mit Bakterien DNA die sehr
gefährlich in lipid Nanopartikel
verpackt ist so dass sie vom Immunsystem
nicht nicht erkannt werden und in die
Zellen eindringen was gedenkt die
Bundesregierung gegen diese
Verunreinigungen jetzt zu unternehmen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehr
abgeordn ich kann Ihre Frage nicht
beantworten sie ist unwissenschaftlich
sie wiesen auf die Verunreinigungen in
der DNA der Impfstoffe hin die
Impfstoffe werden mit RNA hergestellt
und nicht mit
DNA also ich erinnere noch mal ich war
gerade etwas abgelenkt weil ich die
Wortmeldung aufgenommen habe es geht ums
Thema
Cannabis
Cannabis und die nächste Nachfrage
stellt die Kollegin Bcher aus der CDU
CSU
Fraktion vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
meine Frage geht an den
Bundesgesundheitsminister Herr Minister
sie sagten ja gerade die Grenzen wurden
nicht aufgeweicht daher meine Frage noch
mal nach eigener Aussage senden Sie
gerade die Botschaft an die Jugendlichen
wenn ihr kifft fangt spät damit an und
dann macht bin es geht wenig die
Vertreter der ampelfraktion haben sich
bis dahin jetzt geeinigt die Grenzen auf
50 hochzusetzen und die Abstandsregelung
auf 100 aufzuweichen also ist das ja
nicht richtig was sie gerade gesagt
haben sind sie also der Ansicht dass
eine solche verwesserung ihren
ursprünglichen Regelung den Jugendschutz
weiter zu verringern entspricht und wo
bleibt denn hier die prevention für die
Kinder und
Jugendlichen frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Abgordnete vielen Dank für
die Frage zunächst einmal die erste
Aussage in Ihrer Frage war falsch die
Botschaft die wir aussändern Kinder und
Jugendliche ist nicht fangt später mit
dem Kiffen an sondern ist eine ganz
klare Empfehlung wir sagen kein Konsum
kein probekonsum überhaupt kein Konsum
für Kinder und Jugendliche kein Konsum
kein Konsum wir empfehlen dass bei den
18 bis 25-Jährigen mit dem Hinweis dass
das Gehirn dann noch wächst nicht
konsumiert wird und wenn man konsumiert
so wenig und so spät wie möglich aber
die Grundlage ist die kein Konsum ist
der beste und so um und zum zweiten sie
haben dann gefragt also die zwei
Änderungen die Sie angesprochen haben 50
g statt also die derzeitige Regel
betrifft nur das was im in der Wohnung
vorgehalten werden kann das ist eine
umsetzungsvereinfachung die von der
Polizei beispielsweise gewünscht wurde
und weil wir es eben bei drei also bei
also Pflanzen die gehalten werden kann
oft dazu kommt dass mehr als 25 g dann
abget werden können und die die Zugänge
zu den entsprechenden Einrichtung her
Minister kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
sind nicht für Kinder begrenzt worden s
eine Umsetzung weil die 200 m Abstände
sind nicht einzuhalten wenn Sie um eine
Ecke herumkommen und das danach direkt
die Kit wir können ja keine
Hinweisschilder machen um die Ecke kommt
eine
Kita ich habe zu diesem Thema Cannabis
jetzt noch 1 2 3 4 5 nachfragen die
lasse ich auch zu und dann würde ich zur
nächsten Frage übergehen und jetzt habe
ich aus der AFD Fraktion die nächste
Nachfrage zum Thema Cannabis den
abgeordnen Reich
hat Herr Minister sie haben auf die
Frage des Abgeordneten Sorge gesagt Sie
wollen durch die Legalisierung den
Schwarzmarkt bekämpfen und sie wollen
auch natürlich Kinder und Jugendliche
damit schützen nun sagen sie aber in der
gleich Antwort dass ja die das Verbot
für Kinder und Jugendliche erhalten
bleiben soll das heißt dort bleibt auch
der Schwarzmarkt erhalten und auch die
Kriminalisierung ich erachte diese
Aussage als etwas wirr was sagen sie
dazu frau Präsidentin lieber Herr
abgeordn ich darf für die Frage ganz
herzlich bedanken der Zusammenhang ist
ja in der internationalen
belegt und lässt sich auch leicht
erläutern wenn insgesamt der
Schwarzmarkt geringer wird der
Schwarzmarkt wird kleiner weil das
Angebot legal vorgehalten wird ohne
Verunreinigungen dann ist auch weniger
Schwarzmarkt da für den die Kinder Opfer
werden könnten und somit also stellen
Sie sich eine Situation vor nur als
Gedanke es GT gar keinen Schwarzmarkt
mehr dann könnten die Kinder von keinem
Schwarzmarkt gefährdet werden der
verschwundene schw warzmarkt schützt
unsere
Kinder die nächste Nachfrage ist aus der
SPD Fraktion Herr
heidenblut zunächstm mal vielen Dank für
Ihre Ausführungen ich würde gerne noch
mal sehr konkret nachfragen weder mit
dem Gesetz noch mit den Änderungen ist
doch für den Bereich der Kinder und
Jugendlichen in irgendeiner Form ein
verbesserter sondern ganz im Gegenteil
ein verschlechterter ein ein
schlechterer Zugang gemacht worden
und diese zu diese dieses Gesetz sorgt
ja zudem dafür dass wir besser im
Bereich der Aufklärung sein können
vielleicht könnten Sie zu der Frage
Prävention und Aufklärung gerade für
Kinder und Jugendliche die das Gesetz
jetzt ermöglicht noch mal etwas
sagen frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter
abgord vielen Dank für diese Frage es
ist in der Tat so im Rahmen dieser
Legalisierung drängen wir den
Schwarzmarkt zurück je weniger
Schwarzmarkt da ist desto geringer ist
die Gefahr dass unsere Kinder durch den
Schwarzmarkt in die als in den Konsum
gebracht werden der zweite Punkt ist der
wir werden darüber hinaus mit unserer
Kampagne ganz gezielt über die Gefahren
von Cannabiskonsum Konsum bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen aufklären wir weisen
sehr intensiv auf die Schäden für die
Gehirnentwicklung hin diese Debatte
findet derzeit schon intensiv statt das
war immer ein tabutha wir haben unsere
Kinder und Jugendlichen im Stich
gelassen indem über dieses Thema nie
groß gesprochen
ist und daher ist der Konsum gestiegen
bei Kindern und bei Jugendlichen wir
haben das Problem ignoriert und haben im
Prinzip also unseren Kopf in den Sand
gesteckt diesen Weg wollen wir
verlassen die nächste Nachfrage zu
diesem Thema stellt der Abgeordnete
pilsinger aus der CDU CSU
Fraktion ich habe auch noch eine
Nachfrage zum themanabis zukünftig wird
wir es ja erlaubt sein bis zu 50 g
Cannabis aus Eigenanbau bei sich daheim
zu lagern und
der Kollege wurd vom deutschen
handverband hat in der öffentlichen
Anhörung gesagt ja es ist doch
selbstverständlich dass man das Cannabis
aus dem Eigenanbau auch an andere
weitergibt und deswegen die Frage an Sie
ganz konkret wie wollen sie es
verhindern dass Menschen die zukünfti
Cannabis daheim anbauen bis zu 50 g
dürfen sie ja Lagern das sind über 100
dies nicht an Jugendliche weitergeben
wie konkret wollen sie das
Kontrollieren sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Kollege vielen Dank für die Frage es ist
illegal diesen also diesen Anbau
weiterzugeben komplett illegal und wir
haben jetzt die Situation wir haben
jetzt die Situation dass in den
Innenräumen
der cannabisvorrat gelagert wird mit
Verunreinigungen vom Schwarzmarkt
geliefert und wir haben bisher diese
Problematik überhaupt nicht systematisch
kontrolliert somit also es bleibt
illegal es kann nicht abgegeben werden
und somit ist das Problem
gelöst die nächste Frage zu diesem Thema
aus der FDP Fraktion die Kollegin
Lütke sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Mr Lauterbach auch ich
finde wir haben hier ein sehr
praktikables gut umsetzbares Gesetz
vorgelegt was jetzt kurz vor dem
Abschluss steht wir versuchen den
Schwarzmarkt zurückdringen halten Kinder
und Jugendschutz aufrecht haben hier
auch das Strafmaß für die Weitergabe an
Kinder und Jugendliche erhöht meine
Frage ist jetzt die nach der zweiten
Säule wir hatten ja immer auch
gesprochen die erste Säule die
Entkriminalisierung der Eigenanbau ist
nur ein Teil auf dem ganzen Weg wie
sieht es aus mit dem Eckpunktepapier zu
Säule 2 da hatten sie ja auch einen
Zeitplan gesetzt können Sie den
einhalten wann dürfen wir das
erwarten se frau Präsidentin sehrgeehrte
Abgeordnete vielen Dank für die Frage in
der Tat die zweite Säule wird derzeit
von uns geprüft wir haben an die
entsprechenden mitbeteiligten Ressource
entsprechende
prüffragen übermittelt sind in der
Vorbereitung und der Zeitplan der für
das nächste Jahr ja vorgegeben ist
scheint zum jetzigen Zeit t
einhaltbar und eine letzte Nachfrage zu
diesem Thema aus der CDU CSU Fraktion
Kollege
Sorger ja sehr gete frau Präsidentin
sehr gehte Herr Kollege laudbach ich
will da noch mal nachfragen weil
offensichtlich scheinen sie als
Bundesgesundheitsminister Drogen näher
an unsere Kinder heranbringen zu wollen
sie haben offensichtlich die Auffassung
dass Dinge die dass Dinge die illegal
sind offensichtlich vom Markt
verschwinden also insofern will ich nur
noch mal Bezug nehmen auf ihren Kollegen
SPD in Senator in Hamburg Herr grote er
hat darauf hingewiesen dass bei 30 g
Freimengen die sie ja jetzt auf 50 g
hochgesetzt haben das ungefähr 90 joints
im Monat entsprechen würde die Frage ist
ja schon angeklungen wie wollen Sie denn
verhindern dass jetzt bei 50 g also über
100 joints im Monat diese überschüssigen
schins quasi die jeder Einzelne dann
konsumieren könnte nicht an Kinder und
Jugendliche weitergegeben werden und als
zweiter Punkt auch noch die Frage
medizinalcnabis da haben wir ein Antrag
gestellt dass todkranke Menschen
Möglichkeiten haben enger und näher und
schneller ein medizinalcnabis für
medizinische Zwecke zu kommen das haben
sie abgelehnt als amtel wie passt das
ihre Auffassung nach zusammen vielleicht
können Sie dazu auch noch mal was sagen
vielen
Dank Frau Präsidentin abgeordn Sorge
zunächst einmal möchte ich die
Unterstellung zurückweisen das gesamte
Gesetz ich muss in Erinnerung in
Erinnerung rufen das gesamte Gesetz
basiert ja auf der Feststellung dass wir
beim Schutz von Kind und Jugendlichen
vor Cannabiskonsum in den letzten Jahren
in den letzten 10 Jahren zumindest immer
ohne Erfolg gewesen sind der Konsum
steigt
Verunreinigungen steigen Übergange in
andere Drogen steigen das Drogenproblem
nimmt überall zu sie können ja nicht
bestreiten dass unsere jetzige
Drogenkonsum Politik gescheitert ist und
auf der Grundlage einer solchen
gescheiterten Politik unternehmen wir
den Versuch den Schwarzmarkt
zurückzudringen und den Kinder und
Jugendschutz
auszubauen ich komme zur nächsten
Hauptfrage und die kommt aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen Sarah
Nanni harter themenbruch sehr geehrte
Präsidentin lieber Minister Pistorius
ich würde gerne eine Frage stellen zum
Abzug aus minusma das Mandat in Mali hat
ja viele Widrigkeiten erlebt in den
letzten Monaten wir erinnern uns alle
daran wie plötzlich die malische
Regierung gesagt hat minusma solle bitte
das Land bis zum Ende des Jahres
verlassen das kam für viele sehr
überraschend im Sommer dann der Putsch
in Niger mit
dem transportkreuz in niame keine ganz
unheikle Angelegenheit die Lage in
Israel hat die
Luftwaffe auch noch gefordert und die
Sicherheitslage in Mali ist bis heute
auch an gespannt wir sehen es läuft
nicht ganz nach Plan weil so viel
dazwischen gekommen ist aber trotzdem
geordnet und meine Frage meine erste
Frage wäre jetzt wie blicken sie auf die
Herausforderung der nächsten
Wochen sehrte frau Präsidentin Frau
Abgeordnete in der Tat die letzten
Monate waren sehr herausfordernd für die
Bundeswehr dort vor Ort aber auch für
alle anderen Kontingente alle anderen
Nationen der plötzliche Rauswurf nennen
wir es mal aus Mali bei der un
Vollversammlung hat alle überrascht
wir haben daraufhin unsere Planung
sofort angepasst und wir werden mit dem
mit dem redeployment mit dem Abzug
unseres Kontingenz einschließlich
Material voraussichtlich bis Mitte
Dezember fertig werden also vorablauf
des Jahres
das verdanken wir wirklich einer
großartigen logistischen Leistung der
Bundeswehr und ihrer Verantwortlichen
Verantwortlichen kommandierenden vor Ort
und hier dafür sage ich von dieser
Stelle aus ganz ganz herzlichen Dank
gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig ist die Situation nach wie
vor so das muss man feststellen es wird
brisanter die Stimmung wird volatiler es
wird gefährlicher bislang aber nicht
gerichtet gegen unser Kontingent oder
die Soldatinnen oder Soldaten bislang
gibt es auch keine Schäden durch
zufälligen Beschuss keine jedenfalls
keine körperlichen von daher sind wir
froh über den Verlauf bisher unter den
Bedingung konnte man das nicht erwarten
und wir hoffen dass jetzt die letzten
zwei Wochen weiter planmäßig abgewickelt
werden können ser könnten eine Nachfrage
stellen dem Dank möchte ich mich dann
ausdrücklich anschließen den möchten wir
ja auch als Bundesrepublik noch an
anderer Stelle zum Ausdruck bringen ist
geplant dass es eine Würdigung gibt der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten die jetzt aus
Mali zurückkommen und da auch im Einsatz
waren ja das ist geplant und zwar im
unmittelbaren Anschluss des Zeitpunkt zu
dem dann die letzten Flieger nach
Deutschland zurückkehren das wird wie
gesagt irg wann Mitte Dezember sein
sobald wir das sicher sagen können
werden wir den Verteidigungsausschuss
und das Parlament informieren für einen
rückkehrerappell im kleinen nenne ich
das mal und da wird es noch eine große
Veranstaltung Ende Januar geben wenn
dann alle wieder Fuß gefasst haben und
angekommen
sind vielen Dank und von meiner Seite
grüße ich Sie recht herzlich in unseren
Nachmittag und auch die Besucherinnen
und Besucher auf den Tribünen und ich
habe eine nächste Nachfrage von Herrn
Lukassen zu dem Thema Auslandseinsätze
und
Mali Minister Pistorius sie haben
versprochen dass die Bundeswehr Ende des
Jahres aus Mali abgezogen sein wird es
bleiben dafür noch 30 Tage sie werden
das Personal zurückholen zeitgerecht das
haben sie gesagt der Einsatz dauerte nun
10 Jahre kostete
4,3 Milliarden Euro drei Soldaten
verloren ihr Leben was hat dieser
Einsatz der Bundeswehr aus ihrer Sicht
aus Sicht der Regierung dieser Einsatz
der Bundeswehr in Mali politisch
bewirkt eine hypothetische Frage die ich
erwiderern könnte mit einer Frage frau
Präsidentin Abgeordneter mit der
Gegenfrage beantworten könnte was wäre
in Mali passiert wenn wir niemals da
gewesen wären das ist schwer zu
beantworten auf jeden Fall hatten wir
einen beruhigenden einen politischen
einen die Verbindungen verstärkenden
Einfluss auf die Situation in Mali was
übrigens auch dadurch zum Ausdruck kommt
dass die malischen Behörden bis heute
sagen sie haben die Zusammenarbeit mit
uns sehr geschätzt weil wir anders als
andere auf Augenhöhe mit ihnen
aufgetreten sind und stets zuverlässig
unseren Absprachen gehalten haben was
man umgekehrt von der malischen Seite
nicht zu jeder Zeit aber zuletzt dann
doch wieder behaupten konnte von daher
ja es hat was gebracht es lässt sich
aber nicht beziffern Außenpolitik und
Sicherheitspolitik die Unterstützung von
Staaten dieser Region lassen sich oder
der Erfolg lässt sich nicht in Cent und
Euro ausrechnen sondern hat eine
politische Bedeutung die übrigens auch
dadurch deutlich wird dass wir
sicherlich in der einen oder anderen
Form auch in der Region weiter präsent
bleiben müssen vielen
dank vielen Dank dann sehe ich noch eine
Frage aus der SPD
Fraktion
Herr Bundesminister kein klassischer
Auslandseinsatz gleichwohl eine Präsenz
der Bundeswehr im Ausland ist
gegenwärtig der Einsatz in Zypern die
Bereithaltung für Evakuierungsmaßnahmen
vielleicht könnten sie da etwas zum
Sachstand und zu den weiteren
Perspektiven
sagen frau Präsidentin Herr sehr geehrte
Abgeordneter in der Tat wir waren sehr
früh und sehr schnell dort haben die
Kräfte aufwachsen lassen in dem Maße
dass wir erforderlich gehalten haben um
jederzeit und schnell reagieren zu
können falls die Lage im Nahen Osten
Israel im Libanon eskaliert und wir
Staatsbürgerinnen und Staatsbürger
rausholen müssen die Situation ist nicht
so eskaliert dass das bislang notwendig
geworden ist deswegen denken wir jetzt
darüber nach ein Großteil des Personals
früher rauszuholen aber jederzeit
handlungsfähig zu bleiben mit den
seegehenden Einheiten und schnell
rückverlegefähig zu bleiben für den Fall
einer doch noch eintretenden Eskalation
die eine Evakuierung notwendig machen
könnte
und dann habe ich noch eine Nachfrage
von Herrn
Brandner vielen Dank ich habe die Frage
des Kollegen Rüdiger Lukassen greife ich
noch mal auf der hat ja eine konkrete
auf Tatsachen basierende Frage gestellt
was hat der Einsatz gebracht jetzt haben
sie rhetorisch mit einer hypothetischen
Gegenfrage geantwortet das ist natürlich
kann man so machen muss aber nicht
unbedingt klappen sie haben selber
gesagt ja es hat was gebracht also wir
haben eine mehr oder weniger
abgeschlossene ver die könen Sie
beurteilen das was sie rorisch da
reingeflochten haben ist im luftleeren
Raum noch mal konkret die Frage wenn sie
sagen ja der einsat hat was gebracht was
denn Präsidentin abgeord eine
interessante Interpretation von Frage
und Antwort den die Frage basierte nicht
auf Tatsachen aber davon mal ganz
losgels wir jeden Auslandseinsatz dann
wenn er abgeschlossen ist evaluieren und
ausarbeiten und eine Manöverkritik
wie im militärischen Sinne machen diese
diese Manöverkritik hat noch nicht
stattgefunden weil der Einsatz noch
nicht abgeschlossen ist wir werden das
entlang der Kriterien die wir uns
gemeinsam gegeben haben tun und dann
werden wir das in den einschlägigen
Ausschüssen vortragen und diskutieren so
wie sich das
[Applaus]
gehört vielen Dank dann sehe ich hierzu
keine weiteren Nachfragen mehr zum Thema
Auslandseinsätze dann der nächste
Hauptfrage Steller ist für die AFD
Fraktion Kai Uwe
Ziegler ST noch danke Frau Präsidentin
meine Frage geht an den
Verteidigungsminister bistorius und zwar
hatten sie bei der regierungsbefragung
im Mai diesen Jahres auf die Frage warum
die Beibehaltung der Corona impflicht
für Soldatinnen und Soldaten weiter
bestehen bleibt folgende Antwort gegeben
dass die abwegung aller Risiken
eindeutig dazu führt dass die covid-19
Impfung der bessere Weg ist das ist ihr
Zitat darauf hatte eine Dame bei frag
den Staat die das
Verteidigungsministerium gefragt bitte
senden Sie mir alle Unterlagen Studien
die für die abwegung der Risiken
herangezogen worden sind die Antwort des
Verteidigungsministeriums war nach an
Auskunft des
Bundesverteidigungsministeriums für die
Verteidigung gibt es zur Aussage des
Verteidigungsministers bis Boris
Pistorius am
24.05.23 bei der regierungsbefragung im
Bundestag keine Unterlagen die seine
Aussagen zugrunde liegen damit ist die
Aussage dass Risiken abgewogen worden
sind nicht
begründbar gibt es eine risikon
Nutzenanalyse die jetzt aktuell vorliegt
um die Duldungspflicht weiter aufrecht
zualten danke Herr Minister Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Abgeordneter sie werden
nicht von mir erwarten dass ich jetzt
auf etwas was sie mir hier vorlegen was
ich nicht kenne antworte das müssen Sie
mir bitte nachsehen dass ich das nicht
tun würde ich würde gerne wissen wer die
Quelle ist wer die Frage gestellt und
beantwortet hat das Recht müssen sie mir
zugestehen im übrigen gilt
unverändert im übrigen gilt unverändert
die die covid-19 Impfung ist der beste
Schutz vor vor schweren voll
Krankheitsverläufen der beste Schutz vor
Ansteckung und das ist nach wie
vor sie können vor einer Weitergabe der
Ansteckung aber
es macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn mit
ihnen über Corona und covid Impfung zu
diskutieren ich beantworte gerne Ihre
Frage und deswegen werden wir jee
regelmäßig abwägen und evaluieren ob die
impf Empfehlungen noch gültig sind was
das Paul erlich Institut was das was die
einschlägigen anderen Institute dazu
sagen und wir wägen weiter konsequent
und sehr sorgfältig ab was steht auf der
ein Seite Gemeinwohl äh sprich
Einsatzfähigkeit der Bundeswehr und
Fürsorgepflicht und was ST auf der
anderen Seite Eingriff in Grundrechte
von Soldatinnen und Soldaten durch eine
Duldungspflicht und diese bei dieser
abwegung kommen wir unverändert zu dem
Ergebnis dass die Duldungspflicht
gerechtfertigt und notwendig ist danke
Herr ziieler sie haben die Möglichkeit
zu einer
Nachfrage vielen vielen Dank für die
Antwort wenn wir nicht kompetent sind
vielleicht ist es ja das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht das hat sie mit
Schreiben vom
29 hat sich mit Schreiben vom 17 Juli 23
aufgefordert sich bis zum 29 September
diesen Jahres eindeutig zu äußern welche
Schritte zur Evaluierung der covid-19
Impfung im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium
angestrengt worden sind sie haben eigene
Krankenhäuser sie haben eigene
Universitäten das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht ist ja wohl
eine Kompetenz und ich frage sie wie
wollen Sie auf diese Anfrage und
Nachfrage des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts
reagieren vielen Dank lieber
Abgeordneter zum ersten ich widerspreche
ausnahmsweise nicht wenn sie mir ein
Wort in den Mund legen was ich nicht ich
gesagt habe was ihre Kompetenz betrifft
zum
zweiten zum zweiten auch kenne ich diese
Entscheidung des
Bundesverwaltungsgericht ich bin nicht
Verwaltungschef der zuständigen
Abteilung ich weiß dass das Kommando
Sanitätsdienst regelmäßig den
Evaluierungsprozess durchführt darauf
setze ich darauf baue ich das sind die
Experten die sich der medizinischen
Expertise auch andere bewerten alles
andere ist Kaffeesatzleserei
danke vielen Dank ich habe eine
Nachfrage von Tino Sorge
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehr der Herr Minister Pistorius mich
würde interessieren dass ja eben zurecht
auf die gesundheitspolitischen Aspekte
innerhalb der Truppe auf die
Fürsorgepflicht hingewiesen haben
inwieweit sie gegebenenfalls Probleme
auf sich zukommen sehen als Dienstherr
bei einer Cannabis Freigabe auch für die
Truppe also was würde das heißen
insbesondere im Hinblick auf
Verteidigungs und kriegsfähigkeit
da würde mich ihre Einschätzung gern mal
interessieren vielen Dank
die Frage hätte eigentlich zum ersten
Thema gepasst
aberauf zu antworten die Frage ist ja
berechtigt auch hier Gebieten die
Fürsorgepflicht und die Einsatzfähigkeit
der Truppe klare Regeln und das heißt
kanabis in den Kasernen wird nicht
zugelassen werden daran wird es nicht
wird sich nichts
ändern und Herr sichert hat noch eine
Nachfrage Minister sie haben gerade ist
es hier behauptet dass die coronaimpfung
vor Ansteckung und Weitergabe schützt
wir wissen aus zahlreichen Expertisen
das genau das nicht der Fall ist dass
die Impfung dafür nie vorgesehen war ich
zitiere jetzt einfach mal das Ärzteblatt
beispielsweise das sagt eine Impfung hat
die Kontakte während der ersten
omikronwolle nicht vor einer Ansteckung
geschützt wir haben sie sich tatsächlich
mit dieser Impfung überhaupt
auseinandergesetzt oder verordnen Sie
hier den Soldaten etwas von dem sie
nicht mal wissen worum es sich
handelt rte frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Abgeordnete um das noch mal
klarzustellen die covid-19ung ist der
effektivste Schutz vor schweren
Krankheitsverläufen und vor Tod und
gleichzeitig ein wichtiger Beitrag zur
Senkung des Risikos von Ansteckung und
Weiterverbreitung das können sie
bestreiten bis zum Jüngsten Tag daran
ändert sich nichts danke
schön und dann kommen wir zum nächsten
hauptfragesteller und das ist Matthias m
für die
SPD frau Präsidentin meine Frage geht an
den Gesundheitsminister sehr geehrter
Minister sie haben vorhin die großen
Reformvorhaben der Ampelkoalition
angesprochen dazu gehören auch zwei
Gesetze die die Digitalisierung und
Datennutzung im Bereich Gesundheit und
Pflege voranbringen werden mich
interessiert welche konkreten Vorteile
die gesetzlich Versicherten in
Deutschland
durch die neue digitale Patientenakte
bekommen
werden sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrter ABG vielen Dank für diese
Frage in der Tat ist es so dass im
Behandlungsprozess derzeit sehr häufig
das Problem ist dass der behandelende
der Arzt die Unterlagen die für die
Behandlung eigentlich optimal vorhanden
sein müssten nicht hat das ist eine
Erfahrung die erste jeden Tag machen es
fehlen Befunde es fehlen Laborwerte es
fehlen
frühere Untersuchungen dann wird in der
Regel entweder im günstigsten Fall wenn
es noch möglich ist die Untersuchung
wiederholt im ungünstigsten Fall wird
eine Entscheidung getroffen die Bar
dieser möglichen Befunde getroffen
werden muss die Versorgung wird also
durch die elektronische Patientenakte
konkret besser und zwar in der Fläche
für jeden einzelnen
Patientenkontakt sie haben die
Möglichkeit ein Nachfrage ja vielen Dank
uns ist ebenso das Thema Datensicherheit
und Datenschutz wichtig welche neuen
Regelungen enthalten die beiden
angesprochenen Gesetze um die Sicherheit
den Schutz der sensiblen
Gesundheitsdaten der Menschen zu
gewährleisten wir haben hier eine Frau
Präsidentin Herr abgeordnet vielen Dank
für die Frage wir haben hier eine neue
Infrastruktur geschaffen um die Daten
schnell und sicher Ende zu Ende
verschlüsselt zur Verfügung zu stellen
in der Praxis da sind Veränderungen
vorgenommen worden die die Nutzbarkeit
der Daten auch in der Praxis ermöglichen
werden die gleichen Daten können dann
auch mit den Verfahren der künstlichen
Intelligenz in Zukunft untersucht werden
sodass wir da nicht weiter abgehängt
werden von anderen Ländern die dort
schon weiter sind als wir wir wollen
dort ganz nach vorne kommen das gleiche
ist allerdings auch unterstützt worden
durch eine Art und Weise wie wir die
satensicherheit und den Datenschutz in
einem Klang bringen mit der Datennutzung
da ist das Prinzip das die besten Daten
wenn sie geschützt sind nützen nichts
wenn sie nicht mehr genutzt werden
können Datenschutz und Datennutzung
müssen in einem vertretbaren
Gleichgewicht
sein bitte Sie entsprechend
auch auf die Uhrzeiten zu achten
so dass wir hier so viele Fragen wie
möglich zulassen können und auch
Antworten haben vielen Dank Katrin
Vogler habe ich als Nachfrage
entschuldigung ich habe den falschen
gedrückt vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
Herr
Minister sie singen ja das große Lied
auf die Harmonisierung von Datenschutz
und Datennutzung allerdings hab gestern
an die fehlerführenden ausschussse des
Europäischen Parlaments das dürfte ihnen
auch bekannt sein einen äh eine Vorlage
zum europäischen
gesundheitsdatenäh Raum verabschiedet
der ähm eine optout var optout Option
wie Sie sie für die elektronische
Gesundheitsakte
ähm vorgeschlagen haben gar nicht mal
mehr vorsieht das heißt Patientinnen und
Patienten können der Übernahme von Daten
äh in diesen europäischen gesund
Datenraum dann nicht mehr widersprechen
alle Behandlungsdaten auch von sensiblen
Erkrankungen werden gespeichert und
werden zentral gespeichert und sind dann
auch hacking Risikos
ausgesetzt ja vielen Dank Frau
Abgeordnete frau Präsidentin in der Tat
haben wir diese Diskussion intensiv
verfolgt das ist nicht die Position der
Bundesregierung wir bleiben bei der
optoutreelung für die Nutzung der Daten
in der digitalen elektronischen
Patientenakte das gleiche gilt auch für
die Nutzung dieser Daten für die
Forschungszwecke und wir gehen davon aus
dass die endgültige Abfassung der
Rechtsgrundlage für den European
dataspace genau diese Möglichkeiten auch
arrondieren
wird ich sehe keine weitere doch Tino
hat eine Nachfrage zu diesem
Thema vi vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin we
der Kolle g miebes ja zurecht darauf
hingewiesen hat wie wichtig
Digitalisierung und und Daten im
Gesundheitssystem sind also da sind wir
uns ja alle einig und
auf diese Gesetze digitalgesetz
Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetz
hingewiesen Herr Minister Lauterbach
würde mich mal interessieren wir haben
ja in der letzten Legislatur sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet mit mit ihrer
Fraktion auch mit Ihnen als
federführendem Gesundheitspolitiker und
da kann ich mich erinnern da gab's ja
das patientendatenschutzgesetz und im
Rahmen dieses
patientendatenschutzgesetzes hatten wir
ja damals schon den Anlauf unternommen
unter unserer Federführung das
forschungsdatenzentrum also diese Daten
die dort einfließen auch für forschende
Unternehmen nutzbar zu machen das ist
damals von ihnen und ihre Fraktion
abgelehnt wordurden können Sie bitte mal
erklären wie dieser Meinungsumschwung
dass das jetzt möglich sein soll bei
ihnen zustande kam vielen
Dank Frau Präsidentin sehter abgordn
zunächst einmal die Art und Weise wie
sie die Abläufe in der letzten
Legislaturperiode beschreiben kann ich
so nicht bestätigen ich kann allerdings
hier vortragen ohne dass also Kritik an
Vorgänger
vorgetragen wird dass wir halt über
viele Jahre diese schnelle Entwicklung
sowohl für die Nutzung der Daten für die
elektronische Patientenakte wie auch für
Forschungszwecke nicht bewerkstelligen
konnten und dass wir dies jetzt in der
ampelregierung
nachholen und dann kommen wir zur
nächsten Hauptfrage und die stellt für
die Fraktion DIE LINKE ATIs
gürpiner ja vielen vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin meine Frage richtet sich an
Herrn lauter Lauterbach den
Gesundheitsminister sie haben beim
deutschen Krankenhaustag vor zwei Wochen
gesagt dass sie für 2024 keine
krankenhausschließung in größerem Umfang
erwarten und dass sie ein
flächendeckendes großes
krankenhaussterben ausschließen nun
haben sie auf die Zug Maßen bestellt
wirkende Frage von Herrn Damen die
Länder verantwortlich gemacht dafür dass
Krankenhäuser sterben werden D haben wir
unterschiedliche glaube ich Ideen wie
das der wirtschaftlich Zustand der
Krankenhäuser ist und ich möchte sie
sehr sehr gerne fragen was sie unter
einem größeren krankenhaussterben
erwarten was sind die Zahlen an
Krankenhäusern die sie für das nächste
Jahr sterbend sehen um deutlich um für
uns deutlich zu machen mit wie viel
krankenhausschließung sie im nächsten
Jahr rechnen
werden frau Präsidentin sehr gete
Abgeordnete vielen Dank für die Frage
zunächst einmal ich sehe kein größeres
krankenhaussterben voraus weil ich davon
ausgehe dass wir uns im
Vermittlungsausschuss auf den Abschluss
des Krankenhaus transparenzgesetzes noch
einigen können mir fehlt die Fantasie
dass die Länder auf diese 6 Milliarden
Liquiditätshilfe für das nächste Jahr
verzichten würden weil das wäre für die
Krankenhäuser wirklich eine sehr
schlechte Nachricht es wä auch
unverantwortlich daher gehe ich nicht
davon aus dass es dazu kommen
wird und Sie haben die Möglichkeit einer
nachfrageevor der Vermittlungsausschuss
angerufen deswegen würde ich meine Frage
gerne wiederholen inklusive die 6
Milliarden Euro äh für die sie quasi
jetzt bisschen so in der Erpressung der
Länder gegangen sind das haben
sicherlich auch ihre Kollegin Kollegen
von der SPD Länder gut anhören können
wäre meine Frage an Sie wenn die 6
Milliarden denn geliefert werden mit wie
viel Krankenhäusern die sterben rechnen
sie dann dennoch im Jahr 2024 ich würde
sie gerne Ende nächsten Jahres darauf
ansprechen wenn diese Zahl nicht
eingehalten würde so ehrlich bin ich
deswegen möchte ich die Frage äh die
Antwort hören wie von wie viel
Krankenhäusern sie ausgehen dass sie
nächstes Jahr nicht mehr überleben
werden danke
schön sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
vielen Dank für die Nachfrage ich
spekuliere hier nicht darüber dass es
also krankenhausschließungen gibt
Insolvenzen gibt ich gehe allerdings
nicht davon aus dass es an
flächendeckend ins krankenhaussterben
gibt und dafür bin ich zuversichtlich
weil ich davon ausgehe dass die 6
Milliarden Liquiditätshilfe die im
Rahmen des Krankenhaus
transparenzgesetzes vorgesehen ist von
den Ländern auch in Anspruch genommen
werden und ich habe eine Nachfrage von
Herrn Dr pantazis und dann noch eine
Nachfrage von Frau
Vogler meine Frage richtet sich an den
Minister weil wir uns gerade auch hier
über den Krankenhaussektor nämlich
unterhalten die Debatte od jedenfalls
die das Abstimmungsverhalten im
Bundesrat ist ja schon Thema gewesen
Herr güin hat das eben gerade auch
nochmals angesprochen
welche Maßnahmen waren denn für die
Sicherung der krankenhausfinanzen
geplant insbesondere im Rahmen der
Bundesratssitzung die Liquidität der
krankenhäuse zu sichern es ist ja halt
wie gesagt von einer Protokollerklärung
die Rede und dann wie sieht es
eigentlich gerade in der angespannten
Haushaltslage eine Herausforderung aus
was die energiehilfen für Krankenhäuser
mit Blick auf die angespannte
Haushaltslage betrifft herzlichen
Dank sehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte abgeordnet vielen Dank für die
Frage zuunächst einmal die 6 Milliarden
Liquidität im Krankenhaus
Transparenzgesetz betreffen minder löse
die in der Pflege in den letzten Jahren
bei den Krankenhäusern aufgelaufen sind
die wurden ausgeglichen in einer
Protokollerklärung hatten wir den
Ländern zugesichert dass wir den
landesbasisfall wird in Zukunft neu
berechnen werden das angestrebte
Zieldatum wäre der er 7 gewesen
spätestens aber zum
125 dann sollten die Personalkosten im
Krankenhaussektor auch über die Bereiche
Pflege und also Arztkosten hinaus
vollständig berücksichtigt werden das
wäre natürlich eine deutliche
Verbesserung id der Krankenhäuser in
Zukunft kann versichern dass die
energiehilfen die wir hier vorgesehen
haben für den Krankenhaussektor 6
Milliarden Euro für die der Bund ja
steht insgesamt ausgezahlt
werden und kin V eine
Nachfrage ja vielen Dank Herr Minister
ich möchte da anknüpfen in der genannten
vom Kollegen pantes genannten
Protokollerklärung beim Bundesrat hat ja
die Bundesregierung zu Protokoll gegeben
dass es einen von Bund und Ländern
finanzierten transformationsfond für die
Krankenhaus Strukturreform geben
solle jetzt wüssten wir natürlich gerne
auch angesichts der
finanziellen Haushaltsprobleme in die
sich die Bundesregierung manövriert hat
von welcher größ über welche
Größenordnung sie da nachdenken
reden wir da über paar hundert Millionen
oder wie fachw in der Fachwelt
diskutiert wird zweistellige
Milliardenbeträge und zu welchem Anteil
soll ihrer Stellung nach die
Bundesregierung einen solchen Fond
bestücken sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Frau abgarten vielen Dank
für diese Frage zunächst einmal das ist
ein
krankenhaustransformationsfor der den
Krankenhäusern erlauben soll im Übergang
in das neue Finanzierungssystem
ohne vermalbare Schließungen gerade für
die Krankenhäuser die in der Fläche auch
benötigt werden bedarfsgerecht sind
zurechtzukommen die Verhandlungen finden
mit den Ländern statt ob die Mittel
bezahlt werden aus Steuermitteln oder ob
das Mittel sind die aus der gesetzlichen
Krankversicherung zu finanzieren sind
ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht
geklärt ich bitte um Verständnis dass
wir diese wichtige Verhandlung mit den
Ländern führen und nicht ohne die Länder
in dem ich hier wird darüber spekulieren
würde und die nächste frageestell
nachfragestellerin ist Emy
zuner ja sehr gehehr Herr Minister die
Länder haben ja des
krankenhaustransparenzgesetz abgelehnt
weil sie eben gegenüberbordende
Bürokratie sind auch die Länder
ihrer Partei und deswegen meine Frage
also man kann ja jetzt
Spieler Trick so kommt zumindest einen
vor das kann man schon machen aber am
Ende geht's ja daradum dass wir die
Liquidität sichern müssen um die
Versorgung zu organisieren und deswegen
dann die Frage im Vermittlungsausschuss
natürlich werden sie das Geld dann wenn
es keine Zustimmung gibt einfach nicht
geben oder können die Länder trotzdem
mit Geld rechnen auch wenn Sie natürlich
zurecht sagen die zusätzliche Bürokratie
die lehnen wir für unsere Krankenhäuser
nachvollziehbar ab weil es eine massiv
belastete Berufsgruppe ist und die nicht
noch zusätzlich belastet werden soll mit
bokiten frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Frau abgeordnet vielen Dank für diese
Frage zunächst einmal der erste Satz in
Ihrer Frage war falsch mehrheitlich
haben die Länder die SPD geführt sind
für dieses Transparenzgesetz im
Bundesrat gestimmt es waren hegen die
unionsgeführten Länder die hier
tatsächlich gegen diese Reform gestimmt
haben das ist mir unverständlich weil
die Länder also hier im Prinzip dann
ihren eigenen Krankenhäusern sehr
wichtige Liquidität vorenthalten würde
und ich wage mir gar nicht vorzustellen
was das bedeuten wird aber ich gehe
davon aus dass auch die unionsgeführten
Länder zum Schluss hier vernünftig sind
und ihre krankenhäuse nicht im Stich
lassen
werden Wagner ist der nächste
nachfragende zum Thema
krankenhausreform dank frau Präsidentin
se Herr min Minister es geht um die
finanzielle Lage von unseren
Krankenhäusern jetzt gibt es viele
Gründe warum unsere Krankenhäuser in
Deutschland rote Zahlen schreiben ein
Grund ist mit Sicherheit auch die
energiekostenituation die hohen
Energiekosten und der Fakt dass Kranken